le directeur général des services de la
communauté d'agglomération du pays noor
martinique est avec nous ce matin dans
ce sens qu'a dit jean jacques un à ryan
et sami bonjour bonjour monsieur le ton
le pays nord martinique la zone la plus
défavorisée de l'île si l'on en croit
l'insee martinique qui était venue il ya
quelques semaines robert a présenté des
données statistiques sur cap nord sa
démographie ses richesses son potentiel
économique quand même on va rappeler que
cap nore ses dix-huit communes et 104
1000 habitants quels seraient les
leviers jean-jacques 1 à ryanair a mis à
actionner pour que 4 ne soit plus là
elle ne sera plus la plus mal lotie
évidemment bon mot d'éducation ce n'est
pas une nouveauté que de croo voir que
la martinique se dépeuple cap nord est
particulièrement touché le nord de la
martinique est particulièrement touché
la population vieillit et l'exode des
jeunes pèse sur toute la martinique et
en particulier sur cap nord donc dès le
départ les élus ont mené des politiques
et la mandature actuelle et le président
actuel à mener des politiques afin d'une
part de régénérer un peu ce que le nord
représentée en l'occurrence toutes les
richesses du nord parce que il n'y a pas
que des choses négatives mais il ya
énormément de richesse le nord est
considérée comme le grenier de la
martinique le nord est quand même je
dirais le le coeur même de ce qui a fait
la martinique et on peut prendre
l'exemple de saint pierre au départ et
nous devrons et les élus m'ont demandé
et mines évidemment de mettre en oeuvre
toutes les politiques qu'ils ont
souhaité se séparer de sa pierre
justement est dernièrement il ya eu une
rencontre par exemple entre le parc
naturel régional et la ville de saint
pierre sur l'inscription des pitons de
la martinique au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco cap nord à quelque chose à voir
là dedans a quelque chose à faire alors
cette démarche ambitieuse et très
intéressante en terme de visibilité de
rayonnement participent autant pour le
cul pour le nord que pour la martinique
au rayonnement de la martinique en
général
donc c'est une action qui est menée au
niveau de l'échangeur institutionnels
territoriale et louis cap nord est
associé en tant que participant en tant
que donneur d'avis pour mener à bien
cette ambition très très intéressante
pour la martinique je crois pour la
france en général
ordinairement madeleine de grandmaison
qui l'ancien député de la martinique et
à votre place pour nous parler de sa
vision du nord de son tiroir l'ancien
député à l'origine de convergence du
pays d'accueil touristique du planeur
martinique
elle a tracé une voie un chemin qui est
tombé en désuétude selon elle le
tourisme vert le tiroir qui doivent être
des atouts vous ressentez une sorte d'
en vie par exemple des élus de cap nord
de travailler sur cette voie alors je
suis arrivé en novembre
et ça fait quatre mois et je peux vous
dire que oui l'envié est là
les élus m'ont bien demandé de
développer de continuer à développer le
tourisme vert et rural par le biais des
gîtes ruraux des randonnées de la
restauration et on sait très bien et
l'exemple du carbet montre bien que le
nord est recherché le tourisme culturel
et patrimonial et là nous avons des
actions que nous menons sur le musée
gauguin au carbone par exemple d'homme
au prêcheur la maison du bellay à
sainte-marie et le projet de viveo
lorrain donc beaucoup d'action je
pourrais aussi parler naturellement du
tourisme bleus les haines de mouillage
une grande action que nous menons aussi
l'appui à différentes manifestations et
en l'occurrence le martinique surf pro
et nous souhaitons les élus souhaitent
aborder aussi le tourisme de loisirs et
nous sommes d'ores et déjà en
pourparlers avec des investisseurs alors
tout à l'heure jean-jacques un arrière
mais sony vous parlez de la martinique
grogner que du nord grenier de la
martinique avec par exemple cette
commune du gourmande produire c'est bien
des produits de qualité la
diversification l'autosuffisance
alimentaire cher au président de cap
nord alfred monthieux une agriculture
nourricière et tanguay qui n'empoisonne
pas c'est possible
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire alors
vous le dit justement c'est vrai que le
territoire du nord est et a été et est
le grenier de la martinique on sait que
l'activité agricole il ya prépondérante
pour autant nous disposons d'un gisement
énorme de ressources naturelles et
énergétiques
donc il y à une sorte de volonté de
concilier ce qui peut être les a tous
les enjeux de cap nord avec l'innovation
est d'ores et déjà il ya des défis à
relever naturellement mais le président
et les élus ont fait appel à moi pour
mettre en oeuvre ses politiques
donc aujourd'hui l'innovation n'est pas
antinomique avec des richesses du nord
et c'est bien selon ses spécificités du
nord que nous dit que nous agissons
alors la population souhaite
effectivement qu'on la population du
nord car il souhaite surtout qu'on
regarde cette partie de l'île
différemment les agriculteurs font une
demande par exemple d'une meilleure
reconnaissance de leur produit une
collectivité comme cap nord peut aider à
cela on rappelle quand même que les
communautés d'agglomérations sont des
outils du développement économique comme
la 7e par exemple alors tout à fait donc
ça c'est un chantier très important le
développement économique
donc nous avons d'ores et déjà décidé de
dynamiser les zones d'activités
existantes
j'en ai parlé donc il ya des zones
d'activités comme la zac de jean-roger
ou la zone de la bac de tri dit et qui
sont des zones d'activités qui sont sous
la responsabilité de cap nord est d'ores
et déjà nous procédons à ce
développement nous installons aussi des
entreprises sur ces zones d'activités
donc nous créons des pépinières
d'entreprises et nous les accompagnons
de façon là aussi à créer le cas échéant
aussi de l'emploi parce que ça aussi
c'est quelque chose qui peut concourir à
éviter le déclin de la martinique a
effectivement vous l'avez dit bien
puisque on rappelle que en quatre ans la
zone cap nord est passée de 108 mille à
fort 4000 habitants population baisse
est vieillissante la prise en charge de
l'eau sinon pour être un axe fort pris
en charge par quatre nos également
l'intergénérationnel ça te conter tout à
fait de toute façon
constat est fait que la population
vieillit la population vit partout mais
la martinique et le nord est
relativement plus touchées qu'ailleurs
donc nous sommes complètement engagé est
sensible à ce sujet et nous et le
président a axé la stratégie avec les
élus du développement social en faveur
des personnes âgées ont créé de
nouvelles offres ont créé le portage de
repas intercommunal des actions de lutte
contre l' isolement des actions de lutte
contre l'habitat indigne et ça c'est
très important et le plh qui est en
cours au niveau de cap nord participent
aussi à cette action qui favorisera des
personnes âgées mais on n'oublie pas
quand même et le président ne souhaite
pas oublier les élus ne souhaitent pas
oublier non plus qu'il s'agit aussi de
peupler la martinique donc de ne pas
avoir à un moment donné que des
personnes âgées mais d'avoir aussi des
martiniquais qui restent sur le
territoire
et il ya tous les atouts que vous avez
présenté il y aurait effectivement deux
ou trois petites choses à faire pour
faire revenir les martiniquais surtout
de cette région du du nord parlant de
l'eau parlons de l'eau ce directeur
général service des rivières du nord
fournissent 80% de la population en eau
potable ce qui donne un cap nord une
responsabilité plutôt importante quant à
la sécurité alimentaire de la population
en le chlordécone a surtout été utilisé
dans les bananeraies du nord de l'île
alors quelles garanties pouvez vous
donner aux consommateurs que l'eau du
nord est exemple est exact de ce
pesticide
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
toutes les autres partis nick subissent
des traitements avant leur arrivée au
robinet du consommateur
ces normes sanitaires que nous observons
c'est peut-être heureusement sont
garantis par la rs puisque c'est bien
l'argent ce régionale de santé qui
vérifie a effectué les contrôles
nous avons évidemment une sensibilité
particulière et une exigence
particulière pas pas pour le chlordécone
nous est tous les traitements que nous
menons avec nos fermiers donc avec des
sociétés au charbon actif permettent de
dire que l'eau qui arrive au niveau du
consommateur est en totale est
totalement sécurisé donc à tous niveaux
de la chaîne de production comme je le
disais cette eau est potable et est
totalement consommateurs par les
consommateurs nous sommes pris par le
temps finalement un cap nord peut
apporter beaucoup à la martinique alors
oui cap nord peuvent apporter beaucoup à
la martinique cap nord apporte déjà
beaucoup à la martinique
je crois que le nord comme le centre
comme le sud ont des atouts spécifiques
vous en avez parlé et le nord grâce à
ses atouts parce que je ne je ne
qualifie pas ça dans jeu je ne qualifie
lubasa deux mesures négatives ne
qualifie pas ça mais ils ce sont des
défis à relever est d'ores et déjà ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que nous
sommes en train de travailler
moi mon niveau de dgs met les élus
travaillent pour relever tous ces défis
c'est là que c'est quand même assez
rafraîchissant et c'est ça fait du bien
de se rendre dans le nord merci jean
genet sami d'avoir été retenu on
rappelle que vous êtes le directeur
général des services de cette communauté
d'agglomération du pays noor martinique
merci d'avoir été dans son caddie bonne
journée